here at Caesar's Palace Celine Dion my
queen she's winding down her longtime
residency but before Celine says goodbye
she's sitting down with our Nancy O'Dell
big news today a lot of news time to hit
the road
Nana Selene taking charge and she's
leaving Las Vegas would you please go on
she made a fun short film announcing her
courage World Tour and hitting the road
as a way to fulfill her late husband
Rene's wishes I was not even sure if I
was going to go into sing again but he
really wanted me to sing again but I did
and you could let go after but going on
tour it means ending her Vegas residency
in June what are you gonna be thinking
when you take that final vow I might
shed a few tears while I was there
I've lost my husband I've lost my father
I've lost my brother it will be
bittersweet
she says she might return to Vegas
someday but right now she's focusing on
releasing new music later this year and
that Titanic themed carpool karaoke with
James Corden whose idea was that to
recreate the iconic Titanic pose their
ideas I mean James for sure and his crew
but I wanted to push it a little farther
I was afraid first of all that if all
the fountains were going to go what did
they make a mistake
yeah and they push the wrong buttons
what's going to happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]